There's another handy trick that I'm going to teach you now, and
it has to do with the idea that not all unique words are actually different, or
not very different anyway.
Let me show you an example of what I mean.
Say in my corpus I have a bunch of different versions of the word respond,
where the meaning changes ever so slightly based on the context or
based on the part of speech that the word is, but they're all talking about
basically the same idea, the idea of someone or something responding.
The idea is that if I naively put these into a bag of words,
they're all going to show up as different features,
even though they're all getting at roughly the same idea.
And this is going to be true for many words in a lot of languages, that they
have lots of different permutations that mean only slightly different things.
Luckily for us, there's a way of, sort of,
bundling these up together, and representing them as a single word, and
the way that that happens is using an algorithm called a stemmer.
So if I were to wrap up all these words and put them into a stemmer,
it would then apply a function to them that would strip them down all
till they have the same sort of root, which might be something like respon.
So the idea is not necessarily to make a single word out of this, because,
of course, respon isn't a word, but it's kind of the root of a word, or the stem
of a word that can then be used in any of our classifiers or our regressions.
And we've now taken this five dimensional input space, and
turned it into one dimension without losing any real information.
A stemming functions can actually be kind of tricky to implement yourself.
There are professional linguists and computational linguists who build these
stemming functions, that best figure out what is the stem of a given word.
And so, usually what we do in machine learning is we take one of
these stemmers off the shelf from something like NLTK, or
some other similar text-processing package, and we just make use of it,
not necessarily always going into the guts of how it works.
And then once we've applied the stemming,
of course, we have a much cleaner body of vocabulary that we can work with.